what uh what did you like cuz coming up
like ' 80s Death Jam is kind of like
hip-hop [__] allore like when we
think about what Def Jam meant it was we
think about the 80s right I think your
guys's logo you know what I mean '90s
yeah so for me it's like uh I want to
know what is something that you were
able to learn from being around leor and
Russ yeah that's and also the fact that
you were able to kind of like just
Thrive under them in like a way that I
don't think a lot of people would expect
like yeah cuz I was a I was one of the
producers and um along with the group
you know what I'm saying like Leo tell
the story sometimes when when when when
Def Jam was was in trouble red man came
to to bail out yeah that was like uh
that that weird era where it was like
jail felony the the ra yeah things that
that was moving and transition between
polygram and whatever they always say
Warren G's regulate help save the label
for a i Leo don't hold no punches about
what he speaks about how things were and
they need money to holding up to but
again epd was the fifth group sound a
Death Jam so at the early time when we
was when Russell came and got us from s
b records because they had to audit and
when we came that was the first time
that we saw that um
where that we was in that it it things
could be better right because we had
number one albums in the country back to
back and we didn't have any money cuz at
first you don't look at the money in the
beginning but then when you when time
goes by and and and we on fire like that
it it didn't match yeah and Russell was
like we got to get them off of there and
then and they got us off of there and
they we signed for $1.6 million at Death
Jam at that time in 91 crazy what was
your uh um first Nationwide tour like
Run DMC open up for RMC was 88 it was
EPMD Public Enemy J Jeff FR Prince Jesus
you
know and the Run house tour was the tour
and and Russell was run told Russell go
get them boards from Long Island you
know because don't forget we're the up
and comings this is Run DMC so they so
at this time the projectory of of trying
to make the tour U run make sure we got
the hottest people on it cuz ja Jeff and
F is on fire so public enem is on fire
and then all of a sudden these two guys
from Long Island EPMD is on fire to the
point where when when um we on the on
tour and and Fresh Prince has stopped
the show and said hold up want to
congratulate EPMD for number one album
in the country me and PR don't know what
what that means right on on Billboard
what do you mean with know but EPMD was
that Phenom he was number one in the
country back to back on both albums what
was it like backstage though like at the
hotels during those days because that's
it was crazy because it was Arenas so so
again to be in arenas and have like the
the czone cases full of clothes or
Adidas or like basketball rims in the
back like the stuff that you hear about
is what it was but we I'm a kid so all
the stuff is still brand spanking new
and don't forget me and Paris rode on
run dmc's bus we didn't have the money
for a bus and run invite us to ride with
them so now automatically I'm you guys
you guys got your own bunk on their bus
I'm on the bottom though yeah but I'm
watching the Adidas walk by every
morning to get off the bus you know but
it was something special because they
didn't have to do that but they did
that's so crazy to think that that tour
happened Public Enemy Run DMC PMD and
fresh prince and Jazzy Jeff wow that's
crazy Run's House and I don't know where
the footage is I always ask Charlie Mack
he says oh no I have it I'm like this
this the only thing on on YouTube that
we can't see yeah there's footage for
everything else it feels like there's
for that one of the biggest tours like
after you know fres Fest and all that
stuff somebody's got to have VHS or
something somewhere in a closet it
haven't came out yet yeah that's got to
be yeah that's crazy man well look I
appreciate you pulling up uh me too a
great interview appreciate that thank
you man the new albums coming uh first
week of April fully produced by it's
going to be crazy because you going to
be like yo Eric was here talking about
this [__] and now I heard this [__] you
know wait to hear hopefully mon let you
how many um how many volumes you think
you're going to end up doing well I'm
going to do another dynamic duo yeah
with with with the young people okay but
all young rappers though right the ones
that know how to Ryme right so um and
then I'mma do a soloist okay um still
under the name d Duo then I'm going do
R&B thing where all the R&B acts that
that people not talking about I'm
putting them together too that's going
to be hard there it is man don't forget
it's an easy process this is like you do
this in your sleep my is in my like a
lot it's nothing well I appreciate you
pulling up I look forward to hearing it
man Eric Sherman boom Kev there we go
fire